the man on the street may well be
looking at petrol at a pound a liter we
haven't seen those levels since 2008 so
clearly will mean more money in profits
allison bakke UK had a falling gas at
pwc from both the UK perspective and
from those that are net importers of
fuel I think we'll see some gdp growth
uplift I think our expectation are about
sixty dollars a barrel was it could mean
two percent to UK gdp rail bus companies
will be expected to see not necessarily
immediately because typically they're
hedging they will see some lower fuel
costs as we look forward so they will
certainly be winners and I think the
investor community has picked that up
cheaper fuel costs should mean airline
costs come down and I think there's an
expectation that holidays may well be
cheaper clearly the energy stocks have
been badly hit both in terms of investor
sentiment but also around expectation of
dividend yields that they're going to be
able to pay out as clearly cash flows
are constrained through a lower oil
price there are many companies who
through the boom go to particularly as
shale boom redefine themselves to be
very focused on supporting new
technologies and supporting services
into those energy companies they will be
potentially losing out
with economies that are highly dependent
on oil and gas and with a price that's
continuing to slice out it's not going
to help support the economies which are
in a very fragile and situation we take
that as whele for example to balance
their budget that needs to be over over
110 dollars a barrel Russia Iran similar
levels balanced budget even the sailors
comp on a long-term basis sustained oil
at $45 a barrel if that's where it ends
up bottoming out as many as speculating
at the moment